hi everyone my name is gintama I'm
president of Yale steam here on campus
um steam stands for science technology
engineering arts and mathematics as an
undergrad organization on campus we try
to explore the intersection of the Arts
and scientists whether the Arts be of
the Fine Arts and performing arts or the
liberal arts and we try to host events
or co host events to with various
facilities across campus such as the cid
the yale university art gallery the
peabody museum of natural history as
well as the IPC ish institute of
preservation of cultural heritage and we
welcome students from all different
backgrounds so now we have the
roundtable discussion so basically we're
going to have our roundtable speakers
come up one by one to do their first
five minute ox and then after each
individual five minute talks we will
have the speakers come up to the table
to start our roundtable discussion so
I'm first can we have Rebekah errand
from the Department of Music giving a
talk on on letters discovery and
collaboration I was told to be
provocative back in the summer of 2012 I
ran across a short article written in
1938 by the great theatre historian
young Frandsen in which she gave a very
brief account of an archive he had
encountered he wrote in my translation
the Netherlands possess a postal museum
in The Hague where among other
curiosities one may find a certain
number of dead letters as it turns out
there are some 2,600 letters collected
between 1689 and 1707 along with the
travel trunk that had been their home
for about 300 years now in the museum
for community con see the letters
surprisingly remain in their folded
States
and around 600 of them have never been
opened yet somehow little attention had
been paid to the collection that is
until my team signed sealed &
undelivered announced a project that
aims to test the limits of how
scholarship and experimentation can go
using one circumscribe set of sources I
could at this point tell you the whole
back story of how for academics a
conservator and a curator came together
accidentally on purpose and how a
seventh was taken from us too soon but
left us her own archives and hopes of
continuing her work instead I'll cut to
the point when it went public for the
reactions that these dead letters have
recently received raised question about
the power of letters the nature of
discovery has portrayed in the media and
the public cooperative nature of
scholarship today all six of us were so
excited about this collection that we
thought we should spread the news Daniel
learned of an opportunity for a short
article to be published in BBC history
magazine in November of 2015 we
therefore times the announcement of our
first grant as well as press releases
from our respective universities and the
museum and the launching of our project
website to coincide with the newsstand
date but it was not the BBC history
article that end up making the big
splash mostly because it was not
published online instead the watershed
public moment was a story by maeve
Kennedy in The Guardian the next day
that article was shared tens of
thousands of times you can see on the
slide and received hundreds of comments
to our surprise some forty percent of
the traffic to Kennedy's article was
directed from reddit and other articles
as well as TV and radio interviews
proliferated around the globe over the
next few months some of these were
written with the direct input of our
team others were simply translations or
adaptations I admit that we have lost
track of all the spin of articles one
interesting feature that I have noted
though is the proliferation of discovery
story
it seems that journalists or perhaps
their audiences still have a
predilection for stories about the lone
scholar making important discoveries
depending on the source Daniel
discovered the trunk or maybe it was
David sometimes i discovered the trunk
rarely it was Medina and never Jana this
interesting feature makes me want to add
the words all by himself to the moniker
lone scholar it also raises questions
about the treatment of conservators and
curators as opposed to academics in
truth none of us discovered it at all we
merely brought it to public attention
and are fortunate enough to live in a
time when word spreads much faster and
much more widely than it did when those
letters were written and like the
postmasters who collected them who
employed a bevy of personnel none of us
could do this work alone thanks to the
volume of commentary on these many
articles much bit on Facebook we can now
think of the public as further
participants in this project the
commentary has been instructive
inspiring and challenging a number of
themes have emerged general excitement
is one how great would it be to have
made such a discovery pretty great
comments on the material beauty of the
letters and the complexity of their
folding are common and many people
express how much they miss receiving
hard letters in today's world of
disappearing texts another common theme
and one that I find particularly
thought-provoking has to do with the
issue privacy is it ethical or even
legal to be opening others mail of
course these letters are so old that
they are most assuredly in the public
domain but the question about ethics is
valid especially considering the fact
that many of the intended recipients and
the writers themselves were marginalized
in their own time is not for nothing
that the letters went undelivered so how
can we as scholars and allied
disciplines academics conservators
curators imaging and technology experts
responsibly and ethically present their
stories without further marginalizing
these people whose stories and
experience
still resonate today I believe it is
important that we endeavor to do so for
as one commentator on the Guardian
website remarked if only someone tried
to read all the undelivered messages
that we keep inside us too if only thank
you will hear from Ian McClure from Yale
University art gallery and I PCH
conservation lab making the invisible
visible right good morning everyone
Annika and I have decided to share this
talk as we work very closely together
our labs are actually adjacent to each
other on West Campus I wanted to really
concentrate in some concrete examples
the digital revolution that's happened
affects us particularly conservation it
is now so universal that to describe it
in detail would take hours so I thought
I'd concentrate on some ways in which
the traditional technology knology and
how it is used has been completely
revolutionized by digital technology and
I'd start with this image of a painting
in the art gallery by Titian it was
recently discovered due to a mix-up in
an academic article on it in the 1920s
where the photographs got reversed with
a copy and so when it was given to the
gallery in 1956 it was assumed it was
the copy and it went into storage and
only came to light when we were actually
asked to examine it by somebody from the
Metropolitan Museum and we suddenly
realized we were actually looking in the
original
not a copy and one of the reasons why we
were able to come to that conclusion was
by taking an x-ray and this is an x-ray
of the painting and if you look very
very carefully you can see just in the
upper center the I the true left eye of
the sitter but behind it this round
shape which seems to be after close
looking a shape of a woman but in fact
the x-ray itself is very hard to
decipher partly because the x-ray is a
record of the elements that the X rays
pass through some are denser than others
so you have some pigments which absorb
x-rays and then you also have thicker
structures like the cradle on the back
of the panel this lattice work which
supports the thinned restored panel and
so one problem is to make these things
more visible and in fact university has
come with of this wonderful piece of
software called platypus why platypus
are not quite sure but it actually is
able to remove specific elements from
the x-ray and particularly this
traditional way of supporting panels
known as a cradle this lattice work it
can detect this and remove it and what
we get then is an image which is very
quickly done and clearly you can clearly
see not only the woman but you can also
see the details of her dress the way
she's holding our hands one hand up to
her up to her chest and the other hand
holding a cloth in her left hand and
this is interesting because in fact
about 25 years earlier edition was in
the habit of painting venetian beauties
on a kind of speculative venture and in
fact we think that this one was probably
never sold and laying his studio until
it was commissioned by the port the
person in the portrait Guido baldo della
Rovere who is a Jew cover below and the
further research has shown that he was
very very fond and almost insisted on
pan paintings mean if he commissioned
them being painted on panel and so we
think that he asked we supported on
panel and Titian was rummaging around
for a panel because by this time most of
his paintings were on canvas and he
found this unsold painting which he then
painted over the top of and when you get
to know works by Titian he really reused
everything that wasn't
just about every painting by Titian has
something else underneath and the way we
now make x-rays is using a digital
system this is the new system in our new
lab where you have a traditional x-ray
true supported above the table and then
the digital back which is which in fact
absorb records the x-ray image and
transmits it to a computer the great
advantage of this is in fact that the
traditional way of x-ray was using x-ray
film you develop it and if you're
accelerating an object which is you know
you don't know very much about its
structure you might take five or six or
even more x-rays until you get the right
exposure but with this system you can
just keep trying until you the exactly
right and although it's astronomically
expensive the digital back and we handle
it with kid gloves in case somebody
drops it although this particular ones
designed for using on site using for
detecting wells and pipes and so the
cases in we are told it can be dropped
from three feet without damage but we're
not going to try but but ultimately it
becomes a very cheap I mean a much more
pratik but a more reasonable cost and in
fact we now x-ray routinely everything
that comes into our lab and we're
finding all sorts of unexpected things
the other system that's a hugely
benefited from digital technology is the
use of looking at paintings with
infrared with having a camera this
sensitive to infrared light and infrared
images when I started my career we used
glass negatives which were sensitive to
infrared which were very expensive
difficult to handle could only be used
with a full plate camera and a nightmare
to store we then moved on to our analog
technology which was an x-ray tube I
mean infrared camera tube an analog shoe
which had very Pro resolution you
photographed it you used it to image the
painting you photographed what you could
see on the screen you printed out the
image you pierce them together these
tiny little mosaics and sticking them
together with tape and then you
the final objectives is a huge laborious
project but in fact new technology with
with arrival of digital cameras it was
discovered that digital cameras actually
if you take out the filtering screams
are quite sensitive sensitive to
infrared and for example their sensor to
up to 80,000 nanometers so this is a
detail of the previous painting the
lower left corner and you can see that
in the top right image that's just a
version of a digital camera has some
penetration and if you look carefully
you can see there are some lines of
drawing which are detected beneath the
visible paint but you can see the figure
in the green cloak his cloak appears
dark the realization that digital
technology and digital cameras were
sensitive infrared LED Fuji to develop a
camera they called the forensic camera
which for a very brief time became
available and it penetrated a little
further into the infrared but that was
soon soon superseded by much more
sensitive infrared photography where you
could move right if further into the
infrared up to about seventeen hundred
nanometers and you can see in the bottom
right hand corner this is the camera
that we now have and it penetrates right
through the green layer of the figure on
the right and you can see the hatch
lines which delineate the areas which
were to be shaded in the painting and so
this is a very useful technology for us
and it's very easy to use a software can
be set up very quickly that's the camera
this tiny camera there which is a snip
at fifty-five thousand dollars you can
also get a much more sense to one with a
different type of sensor which goes much
further into the red but that's in the
order of about ninety to a hundred
thousand dollars and there is a limit
even at Yale but you can see how large
the lens is that you attach the lens
that's a particular lens it's very makes
the best transmission of infrared so the
glass itself to happen as a very low
absorbance you have infrared and the
lens is designed so there's no internal
reflections or anything to
distort the image and the other very
important thing about digital technology
is the development of tools for
recording and documenting work and one
major project that's been going on which
here at Yale has been led by Christine
McCarthy whose achievements over to the
library here is conservation space which
is a melon sponsored project where we
will are designing from the root up a
system of documentation which would
cover every aspect of conservation
treatment examination materials and
techniques and would have the ability to
link to archives of photographs that are
stored for example on media manager and
this system has now been in development
for several years but we're getting
close to having a beginning this I think
is this summer or in the for we're going
to have as a working model to try out
the beta version so I think this will be
a huge step forward for conservation
documentation it'll allow much better
communication between conservators but
the ability to see things across as it
were continents and exchange a problem I
just thought I'd put in one example and
I think the most dramatic example at
present is they Ghent Altarpiece project
which is a jay paul Getty project in
collaboration with the the ear put in
Brussels that's the Royal Institute for
artistic patronage and they've posted is
at the moment there's a huge
conservation project agon with the event
i called peace it's been very carefully
documented at the the conservation is
beginning its goodly is going to be
cleaned now discovered that some very
early / paint which covers a lot of the
original pain for reasons that are not
apparent but this is something that's
available as on-site and it allows you
to get an incredible view of the of the
object itself so just to end with here's
a detail of the angels that the angel at
the organ you can zoom in you can zoom
into the
details of the face you can then also
get an infrared image showing the very
fine delicate underdrawing suggesting
the hair you can then go to the x-ray
and you can see the x-ray and also the
structure that's supporting the panel at
the back and then you can zoom in even
further and look very very close to the
details and this is this is really a
wonderful example of the digital bechtel
technology that's actually leading to
huge discoveries I'm much wider interest
on an object that not everybody can
access think I got our hand over to
Annika I wanted to follow up on on Ian's
presentation and show how some of the
digital technologies have become much
more widely available and can be in the
hands of students and anyone who can
have access to a single lens reflex
camera and send it to max max and have
the filters removed the technology of
infrared reflect our fee which converts
into infrared photography when you do
this with a consumer camera can allow
people to do some of their own sleuthing
and I think I wanted to link to the
first speaker in in thinking about the
types of expertise that feed into
complex projects including conservators
who bring a remarkable array of
knowledge about material technologies
and the aging of materials and how this
impacts the clues that we have to decode
are our objects seeing through paper was
a task that we were asked to accomplish
by the owner of an 18-13 edition of Jane
Austen Sensibility Sense and Sensibility
from the library of tell Rand and the
owner was curious to see a bookplate
underneath the original book played by
teller and that was visible sort of
texturally but not in terms of its
details you wanted to see whether the
book Kate belong to
former lover of teller and and asked us
to do this without removing the page so
using consumer cameras first and then
seeing how well they did against the
$80,000 wonder we were able to penetrate
the paper and visualize some details
underneath it and then again this is
entirely consumer technology with
Photoshop inverting the infrared image
and subtracting the visible one now
allows you to see this light area that
clearly shows a crown and other details
of a crest and then further manipulation
allows you to see this as a carbon-based
ink so this this type of outline was
sufficient to compare it to the existing
bookplate information from taylor-ann's
many girlfriends and establish that it
was not from one of their libraries
often the issue is not visualizing
something that's covered but something
that's been removed intentionally and
this is the kind of work that can also
be accomplished with the same kind of
consumer camera that has been stripped
of its filters that allows it to detect
both infrared ultraviolet and visible
radiation looking at ink that has
disappeared from the margins of the
voynich manuscript a cipher manuscript
in the collection of the by nikki Rare
Book and Manuscript library was a task
that we were faced with our colleagues
and conservators at the university
libraries and with the help of their
imaging team we took a look at the first
page the margins of which are early
attempts to decode the cipher character
alphabet illumination with ultraviolet
light starts enhancing the visibility of
ink that has been erased you start
seeing dark features and again further
enhancement using Photoshop allows you
to start seeing some characters and
often and this is all with a consumer
camera technology in some cases you know
in order to go beyond and reach
something that is truly
illegible we can invest in technologies
that allow us to map the presence of
elements in the inks that have
disappeared in this case the use of iron
and copper as mapped by a scanning x-ray
fluorescence spectrometer allows us to
see more clearly the shapes that people
have conjured up and that were
mechanically scratched away from the
surface of the parchment this type of
different this this type of
visualization of disappeared aims using
their elemental composition is used in
other ways I was really glad to see
presentations about music and one of my
favorite uses of differentiating inks
based on their elemental compositions is
a study that involved Mozart's original
manuscript for the Magic Flute where ink
compositions were mapped entirely based
on their elemental composition by Han
and his co-authors and they grouped them
statistically and found which particular
pages were written close to each other
and which ones were separated in time
and this was correlated with other
evidence from from the paper itself as
well as visible watermarks this is the
example of the manuscript and the
elemental compositions mapped based on
on their closeness proximity to each
other when we visualize differences
subtle differences that are invisible to
our eyes we can also look for things
that have disappeared similar to the
wine ish manuscript in this case a PhD
student interested in the use of a
Egyptian blue on Assyrian reliefs was
accomplished with the help of again a
consumer technology using the property
of this pigment to light up under to
produce infrared light under
illumination by visible light and this
shows how little lost specks of Egyptian
blue can be visualized in the eyes of
this Assyrian
Jeannie and finally I want to well this
I don't know if this is provocative
enough as we use a lot of color evidence
and that was presented by students today
and sometimes the color is not what it
what it seems to be and this is a case a
really dramatic shift wear a blue
hunting bag which has been accomplished
with ultraviolet blue pigment by a
still-life painter 17th century Dutch
still-life painter has been shown to
actually be a green hunting bag when you
take a closer look and it really changes
our view of the whole painting as well
as the meaning ascribed to the color and
the material use itself so my
provocation to researchers is to reach
beyond the typical expertise in
digitization and seek out the experts
who are aware of the nature of the
materials and how they may change and
how we can bring them back to light
thank
thanks to our art conservators for that
fascinating presentation and next we
have a talk by Amy hungerford director
division of the humanities on reading
machines and the humanities thank you I
want to start out with one very broad
statement about working the humanities
in the last 20 years or so and then I
will come back to that at the end after
I go into an example but my my overview
statement is and I think our
presentation so far have made this very
palpable is that historicism is very
much the mode of the humanities and in
my own field of literary studies we're
sort of in the middle or maybe in a late
period of a robust archival turn in our
modes of study so beginning in the early
1990s a movement called new historicism
emphasized understanding works of
literary art in their historical context
and as time went on a lot of that work
began to uncover more and more archival
sources of just the kind that Professor
aren't has indicated in her presentation
so I want to begin with that observation
and then how's an interesting question
that has preoccupied a book that I've
just finished and that will come out
this summer so here's a question how
does reason reading a novel change if
the novel knows where you are standing
when you are reading it this is a novel
called the silent history this is a
screenshot from it it was the first
novel written into an app so the
technology for combining GPS positioning
for mobile devices and bringing that
bear on the content that you see as
you're navigating the web is extremely
advanced in the commercial world but it
is not very well advanced in the world
of literary art so this is the first app
novel and it was published in 2012 and
its creator was a man named Eli Horowitz
who was one of the founding editors of
McSweeney's which is a literary magazine
mainly founded by Dave Eggers Horowitz
ate at this novel and I can say much
more about it but in the interest of
time I'm just going to tell you a couple
things about it first of all it knows
where you are standing when you are
reading it and the parts of the novel
you can access change depending on where
you are standing on the earth so what
you are seeing here in the screen shop
in the map below you can see where I was
standing in New Haven there's my blue
dot and what you're seeing is in the
numbers in the hexagonal red shapes are
the numbers of field reports pegged to
particular locations within 10 meters of
particular locations that fill out the
backbone story that you access through
the app so the app has a set of readings
that constitute the backbone of the
novel and then various writers have
contributed GPS pegged installments that
that fill out that narrative there's a
lot to say about this it's not typical
user generated content it's much more
curated than that and my next point will
show why this is important this is the
plot of the UK now when your novel knows
where you are standing you can bet that
it is generating lots of interesting
kind of D kinds of data about how you
are reading so for instance the makers
of this app could if they wanted to know
know where every single reader of this
novel stopped they could know how many
times people read certain parts of it
they could know exactly what the
peregrinations of the reader were as
they went around following the field
reports that are pegged to particular
places but this particular screenshot
the plot of the UK shows something
different this novel is generating a
kind of sociological data about it's
making that large number 23 in the in
the southeast corner of the UK tells us
something about how novels or made today
it tells us the importance of the
Creative Writing Program in creating
this novel so why does it tell us this
well that's a plot produced
by 23 field reports produced by the
University of East Anglia's Creative
Writing Program where the call for field
report contributions to this novel was
circulated in a department news letter
so you can begin to see even in just the
data that's visible through the
interface of this novel itself you can
begin to see sociological patterns my
arc and about argument about this novels
that then there are two ways to read it
one in the classical close reading way
where its imagery and themes and
characters are interpreted in the ways
that we interpret literature in a
traditional mode but then it also
produces a whole set of novel data that
is not based on plot character and these
other elements of the novel the machine
has really changed the way we can read
what I'm showing you here is a
screenshot from a now-defunct website
called small demons it was this
wonderful clickable online concordance
where you could go to any book they had
in their very large corpus and explore
all as they said all the people places
and things in your favorite books so
this is an image from the junot diaz ii
brief wondrous life of oscar wow page
and as you can see you can click on a
book that appears in the novel here Moby
Dick and it would tell you what part of
the novel of Juno Diaz's novel was
citing it so it was this wonderful thing
that you could play with sites like this
try to take advantage of the social
forms of reading that are possible when
we're reading through machines and use
the data and algorithm capabilities of
the online format to bring those into
new forms why does all this important to
the way we do literary studies now or to
the humanities well I offer you just
this one snapshot of what we all know
this is simply an image of how great a
task it is now to make any kind of
historic claim about the literary
production of any
given time Franco Moretti has been
telling this story about the 19th
century in the 18th century for a long
time it is a problem in spades in the
contemporary moment the problem of scale
how will the humanities deal with us I
will argue and I do argue and I'm
exploring as our other scholars how the
problem of scale can be both addressed
and is exacerbated by the transformation
of reading with machines thank you so
much professor up next we have um
professor Holly rush Meyer from computer
science giving a talk on computer
graphics what I wanted to talk to you
about just what computer graphics is my
field of study because it is inherently
steamy it is the steamiest discipline
and it is the study of using computers
to make and use images for exploration
communication and expression by
exploration I mean taking information or
data and just using images to understand
them yourself or communication you have
something you want to tell somebody else
and doing that by means of a picture or
it just may be a free expression and I
have images up here from some of my
projects over the years where we're
using images to design materials and see
what those materials would look like on
different objects or some combination of
you know of course the world needs more
pictures of cats how can we think of
making more pictures of cats and related
to what Ian and Annika are talking
looking at ways of visualizing all the
data that we can get now from from art
and then
trying to in the upper corner there
visualize some more complex mathematical
concepts and obviously you get that
right away about stereology right it's a
matrix equation so here's my here's my
diagram of where I live what I do and
first of all you can tell I am NOT an
artist i am not a designer I can prove
it with really bad slides but so but
here's my world is that we have the
physical world and I by that i mean
everything outside of the computer and
there is some problem there is some
inspiration there's something out there
that people want to do and that's that's
the user the user at the top are driving
force and so there's this thing on the
road either an inspiration or problem or
need and from from the physical world
they ultimately want to do something in
the physical world again it may be
displaying that glowing picture on the
screen or it may be manufacturing some
object traditionally or with some sort
of gizmo that spits plastic right so so
in between there i want to go from
something that's in the world and help
people accomplish something else in the
world and what I do is is the stuff in
red I figure out how can I represent
this thing in the world in terms of
numbers that I can put in the computer
so I do the digital modeling and then I
spend all my time thinking of
representing the data data structures
algorithms to act on the data structures
systems to put all these algorithms
together and then ultimately create a
series of instructions that will create
this thing in the physical world again
so my excitement my world is is in all
that red stuff I mean that you may think
well how many ways I mean even you know
there's some things that you know some
things like warmth or that doesn't seem
in
apparently like something you can
represent and I love the the talk about
teaching color there's so many ways to
represent this it's so there's things
that just aren't inherently visual and
even things that are like a sphere the
you and II shot Tom and bored by the
time I went through all the numerical
and mathematical ways of describing a
sphere depending on why you were wanted
a sphere so that's what I depend a duo
my spend all my time on and why is it
different every time will it depends on
the user what are they creating how are
they evaluating it what changes do they
want to make there's a huge universe of
possibilities and my job is to do the
right representation in the right tools
to give them just the handles that they
need to do what they want and in the
course of that computer graphics is the
most interdisciplinary areas anywhere
it's we sit in computer science but we
regularly interact exchange or are part
of all these other areas and engineering
well I have a picture there of hoy Cobb
was actually in Applied Physics but I
love talking to her because she develops
new optical devices and just we haven't
collaborated on anything but just the
conversation of the things that she can
sense now or the way she's thinking
about it is inspirational to how I can
represent things and myself I actually
have no degrees in computer science I'm
a mechanical engineer and I got to
graphics by looking at radiative heat
transfer and the same representations
and mathematics for heat transfer is how
visible light bounces around this room
that makes if I was making a picture of
this would look the same to you is what
you're seeing here anyway and then and
then all of the sciences that's Gisela
cajon from from ecology and we had a
project together like how can how can we
have methods for capturing the shape of
tortoises on the move and go Appa goes
so she posed that problem in that
pushed us to develop some new algorithms
for extracting shape from pictures
psychology is essential to what I do
particularly at the low low level the
key to making pictures fast is only take
only compete what people can actually
see and so my friend Bernice I worked
with many years at IBM it either there
are some things that the people know but
in graphics I need very specific but
information about what people can see
but in a complex context and so working
with her designing a psychophysical
experiments to get that piece that I
need to inform my algorithm to make it
super fast and of course art is
everything and graphics this is my
friends Cynthia Beth Rubin she's an
artist here in New Haven we get together
to talk all the time we've collaborated
on a couple of pieces so in part in
graphics were making tools for artists
but artists are also informing us in on
the same kinds of issues that we get
from psychologists but from a much
different point of view if she's been
working lately with people at University
of Rhode Island at visualizing things
like plankton and and she has a better
sense of how do you manipulate the
images to make them more informative to
the person and then of course in the
humanities this is a Barbara schaller a
classic a classics scholar and you've
already seen some things about examining
manuscripts and and within that the
power of computers for large collections
I'm not interested in words i'm
interested in images so we pick apart
images from thousands and thousands of
medieval manuscript pages to try to home
in on the things that are interesting to
the scholar so just that's and it's not
just interacting with these fields i put
the people there it's interacting with
the people in those fields it's an
inherently human interaction and i just
like to close
that that's that's computer science in
general people i don't know they get
this odd idea about us but yeah we
instant you know we have you know we do
love to argue about our algorithms and
systems and this language and that
language and you know what it means but
so we have that core inside but
computers are not natural objects we
aren't like like Oh what is this like
what will it do that's that's not we're
about computers are built by humans to
do things humans want and so everything
that drives our core and all the
variations of the computer vision
robotics everything that drives that is
what do people want to do so we have
this continuing conversation with people
in different fields that's essential
this is a slide from Nazca I think it
was originally made by al Spector but we
think this as the growing sphere of
computer science basically we're just
going to overtake all of you but so
that's in a nutshell computer graphics
and steam
that was um the five-minute well
hopefully I'm gonna talks that each
professor gave and now we're going to
have the roundtable discussions um would
you guys mind coming up please um once
again I guess I'll go around and
introduce everyone for anyone who's
coming in a bit later so um at the end
of the table we have an echo bizarre
from the Institute for the preservation
of cultural heritage and the technical
studies lab EMA clear from the yale
university art gallery and the IPC h
conservation lab then we have a
professor amy hungerford the director
division of the humanities english
american studies and then we have a
Rebecca Aaron from the department of
music and last but not least professor
Holly rush Meyer from computer sciences
and thank you so much for joining us
today and so to just have a question to
kind of start off were inviting the
questions from the audience as well so
um but one question to basically start
offer any of the round table speakers
would be how did you kind of venture
outside your field to go into a practice
that you know integrates both the Arts
and Sciences at this moment alright I'll
jump in my mind's pretty a pretty easy
answer as a literary critic it trained
in the historicist mode I became very
suspicious of my own claims literary
criticism wants to make large claims
about culture and history when practiced
in that historicist mode and I started
to wonder to what degree are the forms
and themes and ideas I'm seeing in
novels really representative and as soon
as you ask that question and you want to
know what the whole corpus of those you
know now 50,000 novels a year published
in the US alone if you ever aspire to
making historical claims that are
representative and the archival turn is
I think in
illicitly a desire to be more
representative to get the truth right
about history then you have to begin to
ask that question and then you need big
data if I can add to that I'm very
similar to Professor hungerford is
brought up but often the materials force
us to learn new methods so in the case
of this particular archive that I'm
working on we don't want to open these
letters which means that then we have to
reach out further into fields unknown so
at ten of these letters just underwent
x-ray microtomography imaging in London
recently so we're learning all kinds of
new things simply because we're
confronted by materials that we don't
know how to deal with that forced us to
ask different kinds of questions and
reach out to different kinds of people
can I ask about the robot the poetry the
robotic poetry so to speak and yeah well
I don't know ESU and every everyone can
participate but I was curious if when
you were asking the computer to compose
some poetry if if it fools you too I
mean I think in its most moving moments
it was uncanny and a little bit creepy
and you know as a result some of my
project ended up kind of taking on the
qualities of a ghost story so that
certainly kind of lent a narrative arc
to what I was trying to do with it but
no not generally other wasn't sorry I
just I was going to say is what are the
things that very interested me with this
whole discussion was how much of it so
it was crossed boundaries and for
example as very interesting to your
contribution because one of the
unrecognized parts of conservation is
documentation and a lot of it is
extremely routine and I was immediately
thinking of one of the things we want to
do with conservation space to be able to
generate reports which are detailed but
aren't simply written by hand every time
so we can actually develop things I mean
for example we're working on a project
in the moment in our lab which is a huge
altarpiece the only conservation record
or we have odd is from the 1960s which
says stopped a jutsu problem so is there
any kind of system which actually help I
think is I thought your thing was
particularly interesting in that context
a lot of the projects that you talked
about particularly within the humanities
is our projects that are now team-based
and you made a very good point of it's a
team but I wonder coming out of
disciplines that were traditionally that
solo individual solo researcher how our
team based projects and the publications
that come out of it how are you finding
any tensions in your disciplines to move
the solo and getting full credit for it
for your work as a team member will know
when I submit my tenure file in a few
years I'm this is this is a very good
question because it's true that the
humanities have tended to valorize at
least within the American academic
system humanities have tended to
valorize that monograph that single
author project things are changing quite
quickly in Europe for example nowadays
is all about teamwork partly because of
issues with European funding but I don't
know you know I do I am encouraged by
the fact that for example the American
Council of learned societies now has
collaborative research grants so far
those have tended to go to people who
are basically writing and co-authored
book maybe that'll go in a different
direction I think that the stimulus
provided by the NIH grants and digital
humanities is positive I hope that when
you know my files are evaluated someday
that you know the amount of external
recognition that you receive through for
example getting grants would help it's
been interesting to to see what it's
like to actually then other publications
with people from other fields so so I'm
at the moment just finalizing an article
together with my historian colleagues
and one of us is historian then we have
two people come from literary studies as
well as our conservator and our curator
so that's been very interesting because
he has a different way of working than I
do it's also been very instructive to
work together with our conservator
because a lot of the language that
scholars tend to use or academics not
conservatorio scholars but academic
scholars tend to use when discussing
conservation is inaccurate and unfair so
it's been really wonderful to exchange
with her to make sure that i'm not you
know just rehashing the old like oh
blame the conservator for ruining the
materials because there are you know
things about conservation that we need
to know yeah so we'll see I don't know
but I feel for myself the lure
this particular archive to gesture
towards our let fajr the lure of this
archive was so strong and the necessity
of having a very diverse group was so
obvious that i thought well I don't care
if I ever get credit for it I want to do
this thing I wanted to pick up on
something that Rebecca was saying about
the she used the word treatment of
conservators and curators as opposed to
academics and I am actually a material
scientist and so kind of farther afield
from conservators but I I think that
there is if we look with in art history
there's been this sort of singularity of
a curator and art historian point of
view when it comes to representations or
interpretation of our presentation of
exhibitions and we've often seen that
the information or knowledge that the
conservators and the scientists have
brought to the examination of works has
been incorporated into the essays and
then footnoted and sort of acknowledged
in the back and I think that with with
the we're seeing an increased
recognition that conservators and the
subject experts can can hold and and I
would love to see someone dude digital
humanities type study of the authorship
of collaborative papers and seeing
whether we're coming out of the foot
footnotes and acknowledgments into the
status of authorship I if anyone wants
to pick up on that semester project for
next year that could involve some
machine reading I think it would be a
wonderful to help answer the question
you're asking I think we have time for
maybe one more question or did you want
it to so one thing that struck me about
the letter keeping project in particular
was how like accidental it seemed that
everybody managed to get together and
have the skill set to like even believe
that it was possible to read the letters
without opening them
I could very easily imagine a world
where you just saw the letters and were
forced to open them you know and that
would change the nature of the project
significantly so i was wondering in
these sorts of interdisciplinary
projects do you feel that it's the
humanities side that's doing more of the
reaching out or like the technical
people who are looking for humanities
things and if you don't like the balance
any recommendations about how to change
that it's you know that it's always
depends on the people i've never had a
collaboration that was like ordered from
above work it's always the you know you
were at some place and you got into a
conversation with somebody in like oh i
do this i do that and it's it's just
organic and it's the interest of both
parties so I've worked with a lot of
different people and it's you know a lot
of choosing projects is I choose
projects where there are people who want
to work with me yeah so and it's so it's
oddly personality driven I mean you'd
love it like when somebody you know like
Barbara schaller she for other reasons
she came to my lab and she saw some
stuff we were doing and she just got so
excited and had this vision of how it
could impact her work and like okay we
have a winner let's do a project yeah
one thing I think is happening is that
certainly in the realm of art history I
started Lifeson art historian then moved
into working with my hands as my then
boss told me the that what's happened is
that technical art history is becoming
more and more of a subject within the
discipline and it's and initially was
just seeing as a kind of acts at the
root of connoisseurship and and that's
not really the case at all I think what
can happen is it can really inform
things and in fact when you have a very
precise knowledge of the material of the
object and how its constructed in its
history it can give you much better
picture and I think it's one very
significant acted that Tim behringer who
is head of the art history department
has just appointed a postdoc in
technical art history in the department
that's a really interesting and
fascinating and she's already been out
to see us and sizing up what we can
provide in the way of resources for her
program I just want to add a slightly
different perspective from Professor
rush Myers and that is that in a in a
world if insofar as it is true that our
culture is in a moment where hard data
and social sciences and the sciences the
stem part of steam is is the
increasingly valued mode of epistemology
in a world where that is true or insofar
as that is true I think humanists want
more technical collaboration than
technical collaborators want humanists
collaboration and I think it's certainly
not true across the board thank God for
Holly rush Meyer and others like her but
I think in general what I'm seeing from
humanists is a desire to answer
questions that we know people with
technical chops can answer but that we
want to ask in humanist modes we want to
ask those questions in humanist modes
and I think the impetus to collaborate
the other way comes when people run into
problems why can't my field experiment
that I want to run in this town in you
know Azerbaijan and as social science
sort of turns more to a field experiment
why can't my field experiment in
Azerbaijan be replicated in the
Netherlands you need someone who
understands humanist cultural history in
order to understand and get to that
answer to that question and so when
social science or science has problems
that they can't solve with their
epistemological methods in the way that
they've been using them then there's a
desire to reach out the other way that I
think in an academic context there's
also an implication of how funding and
and promotion impacts the the work of of
those in the in the the stem part of
things and considering the impact of of
d railing your work and doing something
that is often considered more applied in
in the work of scientists is not heavily
rewarded and so I think that we have to
consider the structural limitations or
some of the limitations that that are
built into the system that need to be
overcome or explored to allow some of
the direction to go the other way we've
you know scientists we often have to
reach out to other scientists at Yale
who who have cooler stuff than we do and
and better skills and we routinely see a
high level of enthusiasm and and often
followed up by actual work but what we
know that that we have to sort of limit
ourselves in terms of what we can ask to
is this going to be an imposition on
someone's research agenda and how that
impacts their ability to support their
postdocs and graduate students and and
their promotion in our field yes I'd be
interested in your views as the
equipment becomes more exciting and
sophisticated to be able to identify the
history of an artistic piece that you
look at in preservation and conservation
if indeed that makes it easier or more
difficult philosophically on how far you
go to preserve an an object for example
the medieval piece that you're working
on you who said definitely needs work
how far that seems to always be the
issue is how far do you go when you know
so much that's
behind it all well there's one systems I
didn t have time to mention which is
called reflectance transform imaging
which enlarge you to give a very very
detailed topography of the surface and
when this is first begun to be used in
conservation to examine for example the
surface of paintings some of us thought
this was actually a tool to prevent any
further conservation work being done
because if you're physically trying to
remove some later addition to a painting
the mud slightest kind of scratch on the
surface you might make the scalpel in
theory would show up in RTI but I think
what happened is that that's actually
made us very much more aware of the
surface and when you look back at older
conservation records I mean people had a
very kind of cavalier attitude to how
things behaved and now i think these
tools help us to really understand not
only the physical materials but also
what's happened to them in their history
either through being exposure to sort of
hazardous treatments or being shown
stored in conditions that led to their
deterioration so that you you can see
that something that should be hard and
durable has become soft or compromised
by soft material being added to ities so
these were the tools are incredibly
valuable and I think will continue to be
developed and used an RTI also has the
amazing ability to show all of the folds
and creases in paper so it's abyss we've
actually been in contact with the RTI
people yeah and if anybody is in Boston
next week there's a whole week of
workshops about the letter folding and
this letters project anyway that but
what's so great about that is them you
can really see how people have handled
this paper and since this collection was
never handled very much you see that
there are sort of little personal
signatures in the way people fold their
letters which become more visible
through well I'm afraid we're out of
time so sorry we can encourage everyone
to continue the conversations as we move
to the next phase of the program but
before we adjourn and before we thank
our panelists I want to note that we're
going to have some closing remarks from
Susan Gibbons and but if you'll please
join me in thanking our
so thank you everyone for coming and for
joining us today I hope what you heard
today particularly for the audience it
inspires you to think about your own
research to think about questions that
you might have and there are ways to
continue this conversation if you look
at the back of your program you'll see
information about Yale steam one of our
sponsors today and there's a website
there they do programs throughout the
year and those programs are an
opportunity for you to learn more also
on the back is information about our
digital humanities lab here in the
library and every tuesday from 2 to 3 30
there's coffee and there's a and open
office hours where you can come and sit
down with the staff ask questions and
learn more so it's a way for you to
engage and start your own inquiry if
you've been inspired by what's happened
today so before I turn it over to all of
you I wanted to just make sure that we
give a round of applause for Cathy
DeRosa who really put together this
wonderful
so we have a poster session for you in
our memorabilia room so we can continue
the conversations out there thank you
all very much